they're all the California town that
just outfitted its officers with
nunchucks has to admit they got bored
beating the snot out of people the
old-fashioned way nunchucks it's one
thing to get beaten by a cop on video
it's another when it sounds like this
stop resisting I told you to stop
resisting I did the best I got a turtle
yeah they're old Damon Perry the New
Mexico man accused of beating his friend
to death because they were binge
watching The Walking Dead and he
suddenly thought his friend was turning
into a zombie has to remind me never to
watch porn with him
new rule it's okay that walgreens has
bought Rite Aid for 17 billion dollars
resulting in a grand total of thirteen
thousand stores in a combined workforce
of nine cashiers
but they have to call this merger what
it really is one-stop shopping for
looters also if you go to all the time
in trouble to loot and your prized
looted item is a 12-pack of Cottonelle
now you're not getting there early
enough
good to see cotton elegance neural and
this one goes out just to members of the
Chinese oh this one goes out to just
members of the Chinese Sam Cong shrine
very small group who watches the show I
know you're celebrating the annual
purification festival there in Thailand
but someone still has to answer me this
one question what the hell
also I get it that this guy is part of
the festival and and this guy is part of
the festival but someone should check on
this guy I think he may just have had an
accident with a bicycle
new rule the person who paid $23,000 for
a hundred and three year-old cracker
that survived the Titanic must resist
the urge to eat it I'm just saying the
last time someone ate an old cracker it
wasn't good for either
and finally new rule the PC police have
to stop lecturing us on which Halloween
costumes are inappropriate or
insensitive and leave Halloween to the
people it was created for middle-aged
gay man the fake outrage people get 364
days a year to be hypersensitive about
everything there has to be one day we're
going too far isn't just okay it's
celebrated
Halloween is supposed to be politically
incorrect that's why we say
trick-or-treat instead of placate and
coddle now look I've spent weeks working
on my polka hot-ass costume and when I
knock on your door tomorrow I don't want
to serve it on bad taste I want candy
now as you can probably tell I love
Halloween
as far as holidays go that celebrate
ghosts and mythical beings it ranks
right up there with Christmas
but lately we have taken a day of
getting off on pretending to be bad and
turned it into a whole season of getting
off on pretending to be good the
internet and magazines are littered with
articles scolding people like the
Huffington Post's list of frightening ly
ignorant costumes which includes the
completely benign sexy nurse now I never
got the whole sexy nurse thing because
really who's that horny when you're in
the hospital thanks for wiping my ass
nurse and while you're back there oh but
who is it offending Us Weekly recently
published a list of past celebrity
costume transgressions like the time
Chris Brown dressed as a Taliban like
that's the worst thing he ever did the
Taliban should be wearing Chris Brown
costume
and remember when the internet lost its
mind over this get up now it's not a
great costume she looks less like
krazee-eyez and more like John Boehner
but what's the big deal same with all
the costumes on the buzzkill [ __ ] list
like mariachi mariachis themselves are
wearing a costume do you think most
Mexicans wear sombreros and sequin suits
no just the ones who play that horrible
music when you're trying to eat another
when they hate geisha oh who is that
gonna offend the Geisha who lives in the
apartment upstairs there's 12 geishas in
the whole world and they're all in Kyoto
they're never gonna find out you dressed
like them at the office party in Irvine
yeah and of course you're absolutely not
supposed to dress as a supermodel
another one the do-gooders really hate
is hobo which they think offends the
homeless but a hobo isn't a homeless
person he's a classic character of
American folklore a loafer who survives
by doing as little as possible
I believe the modern term for it is
snowboarder
and anyway if I was a bum I'd be
thrilled someone wanted to dress up as
me they have bigger problems when your
life is begging strangers for food every
day is Halloween you can get outraged
over any costume if you try hard enough
Dorothy from The Wizard of Oz may seem
innocent but isn't it insensitive to
people who get caught in twisters or
vampires having the good people of
Transylvania panned stereotyped enough
remember Drac lives matter
and here's the point banning a hobo
costume doesn't make the homeless feel
better it makes you feel better this is
the lazy liberalism in which scolding
has become a substitute for actually
doing something and here's the thing
reasonable people see self-righteous
liberal busy bodies trying to leech the
fun out of everything and they say [ __ ]
I'm gonna vote Republican because I just
can't stand being on the same team as
these humorless jackal offs
speaking of whom the costume may have
been wringing their hands over since
August is the Caitlyn Jenner what
message does it send none it doesn't
send any message except if this guy is
transitioning he's got a long way to go
you